what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
okay so getting into or yeah I guess
getting back into Brian Azzarello
Batman damn part too this one's actually
a lot more straightforward than the
first one and really focusing a lot on
like Batman's youth and in reality
azarello I think really actually kind of
tells us what happened here but one of
the important things to bear in mind
here is it again this basically deals
with the aftermath of the Joker and
Azzarello sort of pain in this picture
that the Joker's existence is tied into
the occult side of DC which is to say
like the demons and angels and things
like that now one thing to bear in mind
here if those are guys who are kind of
having a gut reaction to that one thing
to bear in mind here is this amounts to
what's basically like in Elseworlds
or what if story so it doesn't actually
take place in the main DC Universe so
it's only this impacts what's going on
with like everything that you're reading
in DC Comics right now it's just out
there by itself and that's why it works
it's part of the black label it's not
tied into anything and so with that
happening of course in the the last
video or the last part of the story
Batman ended up running into John
Constantine who was kind of guiding him
through the occult side now it's kind of
interesting here because under normal
circumstances in DC Comics Batman's well
aware of the occult side and the way he
related to Constantine in the previous
in the previous part of the story and
even in this one shows that he still is
but the way that things play out is
actually a little bit different now one
of the things this does here real quick
is it actually ends up transitioning
over to Batman's youth and one of the
big hallmarks of Bruce's character is
that what he was young of course his mom
and dad were killed what this does is
that turns it on its head and it says
seemingly his parents weren't killed in
the traditional sense or under the
circumstance by which we would expect
what is to say a mugging gone wrong and
they were shot and killed by Joe Chill
instead the the falling apart or the the
quote-unquote death of Bruce Wayne's
family really seemed to come more by way
of the fact that like his father was
essentially cheating on his mother all
the time with the two of them have
fallen out of love or whatever the case
was that his family is falling apart of
the scene so they were basically going
their own separate ways and so that's
kind of the crazy thing here is because
if anything is actually kind of a nice
reprieve because one of the things that
I'm always tired of seeing when it comes
to like the origin of Batman in a
different universe is like oh and
there's mom and dad died you know and
after all just kind of grows weary and
it's cool to see it shifted up it's cool
to see that like the the world falling
apart now it could very well be that
like in the next part that like both of
his parents are killed in a mugging gone
wrong but it is interesting to see it
kind of shift up a little bit but the
reason why I say this seems to kind of
take the place of that is the shooting
deaths of Thomas and Martha Wayne are
one of the big in big
why Batman doesn't use guns and this
instance and is in basically an Indian
in pain and experiencing the fact that
his family's falling apart he takes his
toy gun into the living room where his
mom sitting and points her to the back
of her head and when she realizes what's
going on that she begs him never to ever
point a gun at somebody never to use a
gun or anything like that and so that
really kind of seems to hit it the idea
of this is why Bruce doesn't use guns
now what this does from here is is we
end up having Constantine who leads
Batman to a place called a cavern
essentially a nightclub and when he gets
down there we end up finding out that
this is basically occupied by Jason
blood who's a rap artist but the
difference here is that where Jason
blood normally in the DC Universe is
kind of weld to do we just say he's just
kind of like you know prim and proper
and that kind of a thing he's starkly
differ from this version of himself now
we don't know exactly how this ties in
to a chicken which is to say does this
version of Jason blood still say gone
gone the form of man arrives a demon
Etrigan does that still happen or is
this like something else play out
because one of the things you guys will
notice is the actual demon Etrigan
speaks in rhyme this version of Jason
blood is literally hip-hop artists so it
could very well be one of those things
where like when you know Etrigan is kind
of taken over the body of jason blood
and this is just how he looks or it
could be that like jason blood speaks
and rhymes and Estragon speaks normally
we don't really know exactly how all
that unfolds but again you know when
when batman breaks into this place one
of the things that's made readily
apparent is that batman doesn't need to
be here he doesn't belong here and even
a chicken kind of jumps on that and says
like hey you're not supposed to be here
and conner you know rhyme Suman
everything but that man immediately
seizes him and says like I want to know
where the Joker is like I want to know
what's going on with the Joker like who
killed the Joker and as a joker even
still a lot because when you're dealing
with the idea of the occult you're
dealing with angels demons things along
those lines is entirely possible the
Batman could I'm sorry the Joker could
still be alive or be walking around in
some form or fashion of course in this
instance Batman walked into more than
what he was expecting this is a very
very important moment here and the
reason why is because Batman's usually
never caught unawares by either is
because it's it's just the plot demands
for it which is 9 times out of 10 how it
goes well of course that man knows
because the plot calls for it or because
he does his due diligence and so because
of this with Batman being taken by
surprise just to say being surrounded by
guns either it means he doesn't care or
it means this version of Batman is not
nearly as intelligent or as good of a
detective as the one we would normally
expect but of course in the middle of
all this he's met by Boston Brant now
again Boston bran we talked about him in
the last video basically a guy who's on
the hunt for the person who killed him
quote unquote but the general gist
behind him is he's a disembodied spirit
meaning he
habet inhabits the bodies of various
people and then will like help folks
along the way or different things like
that the problem with this is that in
the middle of all this everything seems
to have gone awry like the cities in
flames and it all seems to be falling
apart now again this is mystery building
on mystery we don't know what's going on
here the initial indication is that this
is some kind of an attack or there's
something going on in the city of Gotham
but we're not really given any
information here we're just kind of left
to believe that things are just kind of
popping off and so in the middle of this
where Batman is is really kind of
watching the whole scene unfold
everything kind of goes a little hairy
and a little grey for a second and he's
met by the Enchantress now again
enchantress basically being the demon
that she is it's well known for just
like possessing people's bodies it's a
basis behind her in the main DC Universe
her popping up here and speaking to
Batman to me hits home with the idea of
what's been going on where the Joker's
basically dead he with the Joker's body
was pulled out of the water and Batman
had escaped from the water after falling
off a bridge all indications seem to
point to the idea that like Batman
killed the Joker we don't really know if
that's true or not that kind of seems to
be the case but enchantra's showing up
here as a being that inhabits the bodies
of others and as a character who had
visited Batman when he was younger
seems to indicate the two of them are
somehow connected more so than that when
the bat signal goes up and it's got the
smile of the Joker attached to it Batman
basically responds own to be met by the
guy in the green cloak now again the way
that azarello is doing everything here
and it's very important that you take
note of this the way that as a willows
doing everything here is he's basically
kind of taking like in a Marvel Ultimate
Universe approach to like the DC
landscape and what I mean by that is the
ultimate universe and Marvel College was
designed to be very very grounded and
answer the question what if superheroes
and Marvel Comics existed in the real
world with this scenario here the way
things seem to be unfolding is as very
much a reflection of what the real world
seems to be and so this guy really looks
like the specter like when you get down
to it like it looks like the specter now
again it doesn't have all the glitz and
glamour and the larger-than-life and you
know the wrath of God kind of or I guess
the the judgment of God kind of persona
that we expect from the specter but it
seems to have that appearance now of
course Batman confronting the sky and
basically saying like like what in the
heck is going on you know and then this
you know at least presuming he's a
specter saying like I know what you did
like I I know what's been going on here
I know what you know i know the choice
that you commit it seems to indicate
that one it is true the bit that that
that man killed the Joker and if it is
true it begs the question why doesn't he
remember and three like it creates kind
of a wrath sort of scenario where Batman
literally starts losing his mind and
it's hacking this guy
now of course once it all pops off and
once everything is cleared that man gets
pulled from the rubble by Etrigan and
and it's kind of left to his own devices
he immediately takes off responds to
what's going on with the The Joker face
attached to the that signal only for it
to to appear as though the Joker's there
the problem with this is that when
Batman takes these guys out this is
where things would kind of crazy when
Batman takes this it takes all these
these different henchmen out and
confronts the Joker proper it turns out
to be Harley Quinn and so this is cool
because what it does is it actually
shows the most logical progression of
things for the character of Harley Quinn
in DC Comics it was always one of those
things where she were just kind of
swindled into being part of the Joker's
schemes right like she was trying to
quote-unquote
fix the Joker or make the Joker better
and the result was that she was
essentially kind of shanghaied into
joining the Joker's schemes when she was
kind of brainwashed to a degree or the
very least more enamoured in romance by
him and if the Joker was really as I'm
sorry if Harley was really as
romanticized with the Joker as we've
been led to believe and she was really
that in love with the Joker it makes
perfect sense that when the Joker dies
Harley Quinn would step in and take his
place and the reason why is because it
feeds into that whole idea of you know
I'm in love with the Joker the Joker
will continue to live through me so like
it works it makes it really works and it
really comes together exceedingly well
I'm kind of sad that that Azrael doesn't
really go a whole lot more into that
then then what we've seen but it does
work for the purpose it serves the
problem with this is that you know of
course where Harley Quinn manages to get
the upper hand by literally injecting
Batman with a syringe and temporarily
knocking him out and then goes to
literally like like undress herself and
you know get on with him in some weird
twisted and sadistic situation Batman in
turn seems to like choke Harley Quinn to
death like literally pin her against the
the Batman you know the actual upside
the actual bat symbol and like start
choking her to death now this is what we
started get into the into the idea of
what's truly going on here enchantress
presents herself where at least
seemingly in this story presented
herself to Bruce Wayne in a time of
desperation when it seemed like his life
was on the precipice of falling apart
and then began falling apart and then
what she did is when she presented
herself to Bruce Wayne in that way it
was I'm the one who can fix things for
you I can make things right the idea
seems to be here is that if Bruce
Wayne's family was falling apart the way
that it was and as a child he would do
anything to keep it together and not
truly understanding what he was getting
into it seems as though that at a young
age
Bruce Wayne sold his soul to enchantress
or she took over his body in some former
fashion I would argue that what you're
seeing here is is moon and enchantress
that kind of scenario playing out
enchantress comes out and then kills
people and then goes goes away and Bruce
Wayne yeah Bruce Wayne doesn't know what
happened and so it's entirely possible
the Bruce Wayne killed the Joker that
Batman was actually the one who killed
the Joker but just doesn't remember ever
doing it but again I'm kind of grasping
at straws here I don't explicitly know
what exactly is going on but I would
argue that's the case and the reason why
is because the reflection in the water
shows the enchantress choking out Harley
Quinn and so that's what kind of seems
to be happening is it like enchantress
is the one who's possessed Bruce Wayne
and she's the one who's killing people
but of course with Azzarello it's all
about twists and turns and so just
because things appear to be a certain
way doesn't mean they are that way I
mean it's really kind of tell us what's
going on but again you know it's just
one of those crazy scenarios but with
that being said guys we're go and bring
this video to an end if you are new here
to come as explain make sure you guys at
the sub button to become part of the Rob
core if you guys enjoyed this video make
sure you drop a like and I will catch
you all later purse
you
[Music]